let's talk about the difference between
kefir and kombucha tea which one is
healthier well kefir mostly is created
from lactic acid bacteria whereas
kombucha is created more from acetic
acid
bacteria so we have two separate
bacterias that are creating this end
product now with lactic acid bacteria we
have that bacteria in our gut but we
don't have acetic acid bacteria because
this type of bacteria needs oxygen and
there's not a lot of oxygen inside our
digestive system but we can benefit from
the byproduct of acetic acid bacteria
now when you hear the word acetic acid
you typically think vinegar which is
true but acetic acid is also the
majority of acid in kombucha tea
so let's start with kefir okay and it
has to do with lactic acid that's
generated from the lactic acid bacteria
which also has to do with the same acid
when you ferment vegetables like in
sauerkraut
and kimchi
so the benefit of kefir has everything
to do with the benefit of lactic acid
and the benefit of lactic acid bacteria
so this allows you to digest lactose a
lot better lactose is milk sugar it
helps with regular bowel movements and
especially to avoid getting constipated
it also helps fight against pathogens it
decreases inflammation
it increases the immune system
especially against colds and the flu it
even can help prevent colon cancer and
the formation of polyps in the in the
colon and it can actually help you lose
weight all right that's on the kefir
side where you have lactic acid and
lactic acid bacteria all right let's
switch over to kombucha tea which is
really the benefit of acetic acid not
the bacteria because we can't grow
acetic acid bacteria in our guts all
right so this acid helps with your blood
sugars and it really helps to make
insulin more sensitive and with that
comes a lot of different benefits it
will help you lower blood pressure it
reduces inflammation
it helps you digest just from the
standpoint of adding an acid to your
system
it helps to decrease the growth of
pathogens
and it can increase mineral absorption
now just as an interesting side now
sour dough bread
uses both the lactic acid bacteria
and the acetic acid bacteria which i'm
not recommending but i just wanted to
let you know so which one is uh
healthier well
that's a hard decision because both of
them have their unique
benefits
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i would really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others